[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pierre laurent sénateur secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste français
est l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec
l' agence france presse avec les échos
et avec radio classique et bien sûr vous
répondrez à trois grandes questions que
viendront vous posez lucide malandain
olivier armand et mickaël szames s1 les
communistes vont ils se réconcilier avec
jean luc mélenchon jusqu'à former un
groupe commun d'opposition de gauche
emmanuel macron à l'assemblée où les
élus d'ailleurs de la france insoumise
vous avez vu ça on fait une entrée
remarquée en pack
aujourd'hui deux contestez-vous la
légitimité des manuels macron pour
réformer notamment la loi travail
enfin troisième question l'état
d'urgence dans le droit commun c'est une
nécessité l'a martelé hier le ministre
de l'intérieur sur les champs elysées
est ce également votre avis pierre
laurent mais une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
après le second tour des législatives on
nous annonçait un simple remaniement
technique mais la sphère s'avère
beaucoup plus complexe exfiltration vers
l'assemblée de richard ferrand départ de
sylvie goulard d'autres peut-être du
modem comme elle on ne sait pas encore s
que vous jugez ce soir que le
gouvernement est dans la tourmente
ça fait ça fait effectivement étrange
alors que le gouvernement démarre à
peine qui va être formé
les personnalités que vous citez sont
des poids lourds du gouvernement donc ça
n'est pas anodin le sort qui est réservé
à richard ferron est quand même assez
curieux parce qu'on laisse fillon l'ex
filtre du gouvernement pour des affaires
et on le met président du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale alors que le
parlement va entamer sa va commencer au
sénat d'ailleurs la discussion sur la
loi de moralisation enfin elle s'appelle
plus comme ça la loi pour retrouver
confiance dans l'action publique
donc tout ça effectivement état c est
assez étrange étrange doré et rouge mais
ce qui est étrange également que
françois bayrou reste au gouvernement
pour défendre cette loi alors que sa
collègue du modem comme lui également
cité dans l' enquête sur les assistants
parlementaires impayées par papa par le
parlement européen et sur la peur des
assistants parlementaires européens à
l'ailé gauche en revanche son courroux
sait pas très bien d'ailleurs si
finalement ils vont être mis en cause ou
pas les procédures sont assez longs au
parlement européen ce qui ce qui est
effectivement là une enquête de la
justice qui est effectivement perturbant
c'est que on a des ministres qui vont
être au front sur la question de la
moralisation de la vie publique qui sont
eux mêmes concernés
ça renforce des propositions que nous
allons porter d'ailleurs nous dans le
débat parlementaire pour améliorer
encore les dispositions transparence les
dispositions de prévention des conflits
d'intérêts voilà surtout ça il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire n'importe
quel parlementaire nous permettra de
faire adopter des propositions plus
audacieuse que celle que qui figure pour
le moment dont l'acquéreur dans le
projet mais bien vers le haut mais vous
dites
étrange perturbant et répondez moi
est-ce que vous demander le départ de
françois bayrou et de marielle de sarnez
qui sont tous les
si tu es bon j'ai pas sinon des affaires
du gouvernement j'ai pas de raison de
demander le départ leur françois bayroux
par exemple du gouvernement est ce que
vous trouvez néanmoins que la situation
devient gênante pour emmanuel macron
alors est-ce que vous lui accorder un
crédit supplémentaire ou un crédit tout
court d'ailleurs je pense depuis le
début que contrairement à ce qu'on
annonce cette majorité ne n'est pas une
majorité de vrai renouveau politique et
l est et tous les élus qu'on nous
présente comme venant de la société
civile tout ça en vérité sont très liés
sont très liés au mieux aux milieux
économiques au milieu aux milieux
dirigeants du pays déjà ce donc qu'un
hacker penser tout ça mais je pense en
général à la majorité des manuels macron
je pense qu'on va découvrir
progressivement qu'on est très très loin
du renouveau politique annoncée et je
pense que ça ça remettra les choses à
leur juste place
il y aurait des choses plus profondes à
faire pour renouveler la représentation
politique à propos de renouvellement est
par exemple la proportionnelle d'accord
ce que c'est un débat à l'ordre à ses
éléments d'ailleurs par le premier
ministre lui-même d'ailleurs qui vient
de la droite parce que vous dénoncez un
renouvellement en trompe l'oeil et le
premier ministre edouard philippe a
annoncé qu'il sa volonté entre les
quatre d'élargir encore plus le
gouvernement d'ouvrir vers la droite
comment est-ce que vous jugez cette
intention alors qu'on ne connaît pas en
connaît les personnels et l'air tout ça
ne me surprend pas parce qu'on sait
depuis le départ qu'une partie des
députés de droite et d'ailleurs ils
viennent de constituer un groupe
aujourd'hui nous construisons et vont
appuyer
gouvernement que même ceux qui ne font
pas partie de ce groupe vont très
probablement voter très souvent les
textes du du gouvernement donc on voit
bien que on a une orientation globale du
gouvernement qui va s'affirmer comme
l'elysée à droite oui qui va très
clairement penché à droite qu'à 3 pas
droite
à bâle ça c'est clair on écoute et on
met pas un premier ministre de droite
aux manettes un ministre de l'économie
de droite en place un ministre du budget
de droite
si c'est pour mener une politique qui
n'a rien à voir avec les avec les
conceptions de la droite
la suite tout de suite avec lucile
malandain notre consoeur de la fp qui
nous rejoint l'épreuve de vérité avec
les bons soirs lucile alors vous avez
une question la question posée à pierre
laurent
bonjour les communistes vente il alors
se réconcilier avec jean luc mélenchon
au point de former un groupe commun la
semaine nationale d'opposition à la
politique
écoutez cette discussion elle va être
débattu par les par les députés
communistes demain je crois que les
députés de la france sera soumis ce soit
réunie aujourd'hui les députés
communistes ils sont onze vont se réunir
demain et c'est eux qui vont prendre qui
vont prendre cette décision
ce qui est certain c'est que dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes donc
à un parlement archi dominé par macro
nous allons être convergents de travail
sur beaucoup de choses donc il serait il
faut trouver des formes de travail
commune est ce que ça pourra aller
jusqu'au groupe commun c'est les députés
qui vont en discuter et qui vont après
on discutait entre les députés de la
france insoumise et les députés commune
et notre avis vous moi la disposition au
travail qui sera la meilleure la plus
efficace pour faire du comment et qui
permettent à chacune des sensibilités de
pouvoir de pouvoir s'exprimer
voilà sera la meilleure fodil faut
disent qu'il faut y arriver est arrivé
c'est ça mais en plus je sais c'est
sérieux ce que je vais vous dire je
pense qu'effectivement les députés moi
je suis sous ceux de sa ici dans le
groupe a au sénat quand on a ces
questions à discuter
ceux-là prennent leur responsabilité
vous parlez nous avons parlé entre eux
et vont chercher je vous dis la
meilleure disposition de possibles ça ne
va pas faire dit
nous avons beaucoup de choses je le
répète à féron comment ça ne va pas
faire disparaître du jour au lendemain
les débats que nous avons eus pendant
l'élection présidentielle et que nous
aurons peut-être demain avec la france
sera soumise
alors on va écouter jean luc mélenchon
il ya quelques instants parce que il
parle de vos échanges à mener après des
mots très durs que vous avez changé
d'ailleurs sur un ton plutôt apaisé on
va parler avec eux c'est tout le monde
est de bonne foi
une fois qu'on aura percé abcès qui sont
nombreux et envisagera il ya pas trop de
difficulté toute façon on va être unis
dans le combat
je connais ça j'ai siégé pendant des
années ou bien assis à côté du groupe
communiste parce que moi même j'étais
socialiste au sénat au bien avec les
communistes comme j'ai été sénateur
frank aux joies de la nature combattu
ensemble reprendra pas les mêmes
méthodes on n'a pas les mêmes
sensibilités tout le monde le sait vous
n'êtes pas communiste au sens nous
sommes pas membres du parti communiste
français ça sert à rien de nous
d'essayer de vous un excès ça sert à
rien mais je crois que ça devrait se
passer simplement alors l annexion non
il y aura pas d'élection mais je pense
que si tout le monde est dans un état
d'esprit à la fois comme je les dis de
faire du commun et de et de se respecter
tels que nous sommes il devrait y avoir
des solutions on a bien fallu sion comme
une autre donc la dernière année qui est
passée que justement les plaies ont été
ouvertes est réouverte que les choses ne
se sont pas bien passées et que vous m
ne l'aiment pas parvenu avec jean luc
mélenchon va faire du commun justement y
compris en le soutenant d'ailleurs à la
dans sa candidature à la présidentielle
qu'est ce qui ferait que là les choses
auraient changé non mais finalement il
d'ailleurs jean-luc mélenchon le dit lui
même sur un certain nombre de
conceptions nous ne fonctionnons pas
pareil compris peut-être même dans le
travail parlementaire elle la relation
au travail démocratique bon voilà tout
ça mais en quoi mais en quoi est ce que
c'est un problème que les forces les 29
députés venus de différentes formations
ce qu'il ya des députés de la france est
soumise il ya des députés communistes
il ya aussi quelques députés qui
viennent d'autres d'autres formations ou
des personnalités comme françois ruffin
donc je pense que il va falloir vivre
avec cette diversité là et vivre
intelligemment mais je le répète ça ne
fera pas disparaître tous les débats il
existe il ya des différences mais ce qui
est certain c'est que sur l'essentiel on
le voit bien
face aux projets qui vont nous arriver
par exemple des mois de juillet nous
nous allons faire nous allons faire
front commun
c'est c'est probable enfin ce alors là
par contre ce serait une énorme surprise
si ce n'était pas le cas donc mais je
pense que nous avons en commun ou dans
deux groupes séparés
vous ferez fonds communs oui il faut
faire front commun c'est ça l'essentiel
il faut trouver la bonne méthode pour le
faire on voit là on permettant à chacun
d'exprimer et moi je ne veux pas prendre
parti dans cette discussion vous êtes le
chef du oui mais je pense que les
députés
je connais bien les routes ils sont et
lisez bien les 11 députés
non il vous dit qu'ils sont des visées
je ne crois pas ce sont des ce sont des
personnalités fortes je les connais bien
je vais quand même réponse il pose des
conditions quand même allés poser sa
femme avec ambition forte c'est la
discipline de vote
nathan puis c'est lui qui veut présider
le groupe on l'accepté ou pas ben
justement ça fait si on veut discuter il
faut il faut il faut pouvoir et pour
pouvoir discuter ça fait partie des
choses parce qu t on ne peut pas aussi
ici aussi on veut dire on va discuter
tout le monde voilà je vais leur apaisé
dans ce qu'il disait tout à l'heure
bon donc il faut pouvoir discuter
tranquillement dès qu'il ya quand même
vous avez combien passif terrible il
avait eu des mots terribles
il y avait été rapportée de rentrer dans
un sms à je suis désolé je vais arriver
il avait dit le ps il allait comparer ça
à la mort et au néon vous pouvez oublier
ça aujourd'hui vous savez il y à une
majorité écrasante des manuels moi la
seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est ça il
ya une majorité écrasante des manuels
macro nous sommes avec 29 députés
certains de la france insoumise d'autres
communiste avec d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
de communistes que certains nous avaient
nous avait annoncé on vous avez ample
rayer de la carte un peu vite quand même
et bien aujourd'hui ils vont porter ses
députés la voix de millions et de
millions de personnes
et d'ailleurs ils sont trop faiblement
représentés cesser ses électeurs à cause
des modes de scrutin
donc ils ont une responsabilité
importante sont faiblement représentés
parce que il ya eu beaucoup d'abstention
aussi comme un nom mais aussi parce que
vraiment pour tous les élus parlent que
les scrutins après on aura un scrutin à
la proportionnelle même qu'ils ne
diraient que 50% des députés à la
proportionnelle
il y aurait 84 députés communistes et
insoumis à l'assemblée nationale il y en
a 29
donc on voit la déformation que craie la
représentation politique elle est énorme
donc je pense que cette responsabilité
il faut l'assumer je le répète elle ne
fait pas disparaître les débats chacun
va vouloir être respectée tel qu'il est
c'est bien normal et il peut y avoir ni
compris dans un groupe comme ça il y en
a tous les jours dans le groupe auquel
je participe et jean luc mélenchon
connaît très bien lui qui a été
parlementaire il ya toujours dans des
dents dans des groupes des débats sur la
manière dont on se positionne par
rapport à tel
jusqu en skiff au pouvoir les députés
ont besoin de cette liberté d'agir si
vous êtes de dialogue avec leurs
électeurs si vous êtes du point de vue
idéologique et programmatique d'accord
sur l'essentiel avec jean luc mélenchon
pardon il y a des points sur lequel il y
à des ruptures
on pense à la sortie du nucléaire
l'europe était raconte beaucoup vous
rabâche régulièrement ce que justement
sur ces points là ce serait important
d'avoir un groupe indépendant et
autonome pour les passer ce que je dis
quelle que soit la configuration qu'on
trouve il faut bien il faut bien que
cette diversité quand elles existent
parce que sur beaucoup de questions
ce sera convergent elles puissent aussi
trouver de l'espace pour le mcr donc
libéral que ça correspond aussi à des
choses qu'on dit les électeurs
voilà donc été de vote
que vous exigez voilà que jean luc
mélenchon au contraire présidence du
coup mais la liberté
mélenchon je ne comprend pas toujours ce
débat parce que laisse la liberté de
vote c'est pas tout le monde sait tout
et n'importe quoi nous aussi on a envie
de cohérence politique
on est dans un groupe et au général dont
les groupes dans lesquels on est on
cherche à avoir des positions communes
ont fait passer pas chacun fait ce qu'il
veut sinon évidemment ça n'a pas de sens
donc bien sûr la cohérence politique
mais je rappelle par contre que le
mandat impératif c'est
anticonstitutionnel une somme en sommes
comptables devant des électeurs à la
france a des oreilles connais assez
facilement il disait ça y est bien
selecta et bien c'est tous ces points là
c'est tout c'est moi qui je pense seront
l'objet d'une discussion pourra vérifier
on a vu lité de travail en commun ou pas
on a vu vos différences en tous les cas
d' approche d'accord merci beaucoup mais
c'est de la suite de l'épreuve de vérité
avec olivier armor des échos qui nous
rejoint maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir olivier roussat bienvenue parmi
nous merci pour cette première pour vous
alors vous avez une question sur pierre
laurent au soir emmanuel macron a
remporté largement la présidentielle il
a remporté largement avec son mouvement
les élections législatives et malgré une
abstention record
il bénéficie encore d'une dynamique
assez vive contestez-vous encore sa
légitimité à réformer dont je n'ai pas à
contester la légitimité des manuels
macro à mais cela ne m'empêchera pas de
jouer de jouer mon rôle d'opposant au
rôle politique d'opposants à cette
politique donc reconnaître sa légitimité
c'est ne pas ça n'a rien à voir avec
s'effacer devant les propositions des
manuels vaincrons parce que sinon c'est
pas la peine d'élire un parlement
mais là c'est déjà important serait vous
dites parce qu'il ya eu des procès en
légitimité au soir du second tour
non mais dynamique mais il ya un énorme
problème de légitimité mais qui parle
légitimité au sens où il ne devrait pas
être président de la république il a été
élu mais par contre il y a un sérieux
problème c'est que d'élection en
élection alors c'est pas vrai de
l'élection présidentielle mais par
exemple pour les élections législatives
le taux de participation baisse la
présidentialisation excessive conduit à
ça dévalorise les élections et donc on a
un problème démocratique parce
qu'effectivement élire par exemple
l'assemblée nationale du pays avec moins
de la moitié des français
on connaissait ça dans d'autres grandes
démocraties comme les etats-unis ou
l'autre mais pas en france donc ça c'est
un affaissement démocratique grave et on
ne peut pas rester les bras croisés
devant ça et puis il ya bomba peu
importe
et si demain ils sont élus avec 25% des
électeurs tout le monde va dire ben
c'est la même chose non il ya un très
grave problème qui devrait obliger à
toucher au régime présidentiel et à
conduire des réformes institutionnelles
sur les réformes entre les cas avec
maintenant un pouvoir légitime pour
l'engager justement parce que vous
souhaitez donc ne pas rester
les bras croisés c'est ce que vous
expliquez vous voulez donc être dans
l'opposition vous allez lui laisser
combien de temps à emmanuel macron
sachant que par exemple sur la réforme
du travail
il souhaite agir vite fort par
ordonnance dès l'été bien nous on va pas
lui laisser tomber c'est lui qui nous on
laisse pas parce que il
il va proposer aux parlementaires de
voter la loi d'habilitation
d'habilitation des ordonnances alors
même que les discussions avec les
syndicats ne sont pas terminées donc en
gros à nouveau on va nous demander de
voter une loi d'habilitation des
ordonnances sans connaître le contenu on
connaîtra vaguement les têtes de
chapitre puisque c'est à ça que va
servir la loi d'habilitation
donc c'est lui qui a un problème avec le
temps mais les dix parce que au lieu de
donner au parlement les moyens de
discuter sérieusement des projets de
l'est de pouvoir les étudier en toute
transparence de pouvoir nous même en
parler avec les organisations syndicales
parce qu'il n'ya pas que le gouvernement
quel droit parlait avec les
organisations syndicales
nous sommes des représentants des
électeurs nous avons droit aussi nous
faire notre opinion et bien le
gouvernement veut nous priver de ce
temps là et nous priver de ce pouvoir là
donc nous nous allons avant même de
parler du contenu nous nous exprimerons
contre le recours même aux orres devrait
on écoute le premier ministre qui
précise et justement ce matin à la
méthode la concertation au programme dit
il et comme les ordonnances il y aura
une discussion parlementaire au mot
juillet à l'assemblée sur une loi
d'habilitation cette loi d'habilitation
on va la présenter à l'assemblée pour
que le parlement nous autorise à écrire
par ordonnance les modifications dans le
gros du travail que nous voulons porter
mais cette loi d'habilitation sera
discuté à l'assemblée
le contenu des ordonnances sera discuté
avec les organisations syndicales nous
sortiront avant la fin de l'été je ne
veux pas présenter les régionales non
mais il va sûrement ça franchement ça
fait plus d'un mois
ça a commencé ça fait plus d'un mois on
nous parle de la concertation qu'on nous
dise avancée mais où on sait toujours
rien quand il ya des informations qui
sont parues dans la presse sur des
textes provisoire
la ministre a même menacé de porter
plainte contre certains qui auraient
fait fuiter ces textes donc comment
est-ce qu'on va disposer nous d'un
minimum d'informations pour se prononcer
au parlement en vérité parce que c'est
ça les ordonnances on nous demande de
2 nous dessaisir du pouvoir de légiférer
qui appartient au parlement au profit de
l'exécutif donc c'est une procédure
contestable les ordonnances on nous dit
mais très vite est prévu d'engager
attention quand même
oui d'accord c'est prévu dans la
constitution mais rien n'oblige à
utiliser il ya beaucoup de choses dans
la constitution qui pose des problèmes
on l'a vu avec le 49 3 et avec d'autres
dispositions qui sont utilisés qu'ils
ont constitutionnel en soignant il y
avait eu recours en 1980 pour les
bienvenus ceci rend connaissez aux
communistes une certaine constance sur
la matière nous avons toujours dénoncé
ces articles qui donne des pouvoirs
exceptionnels au président de la
république mais pierre l'an le fait
justement qu emmanuel macron est annoncé
clairement pendant la campagne
présidentielle qu'il utiliserait ses
ordonnances pour la loi et qu'il me
ferait rapidement et qu'il a tout de
même été élu est ce que ça lui confère
pas quelque part une légitimité c'est
une question oui mais je crois que ça ne
ça n'autorise pas à priver par le mot
son pouvoir et je pense que nous nous
battrons pour faire respecter pour faire
respecter les droits du parlement et
pour faire la clarté sur le contenu
parce que vous l'y les gens ont voté en
connaissance de cause dans ils entendent
un discours général dans lequel on leur
dit on va réformer ça va être plus
moderne ça va être formidable ça va
créer des emplois
personne ne prouve jamais rien de tout
ça c'est qu'au moment du séisme nous a
dit on va donner 40 milliards aux
entreprises ça va créer plein d'emplois
toutes les études montrent que ça n'a
pas été vrai mais ça continue donc là
nous non non par exemple que est ce que
les mesures qui figureront dans les
ordonnances vont être évalués vous savez
quand on vote un projet de loi il ya une
étude d'impact ont ce projet de loi qui
dit voilà ce que ça pourrait produire
est ce que les dispositions qui sont
contenus dans les ordonnances seront
évalués nord elle ne le saurons pas il
n'aura pas d'étude d'impact puisque le
gouvernement le parlement ne va pas
pouvoir exercer son de la cloche qui a
un grave problème de méthode
alors juste il n'est au contenu
évidemment parce que là on parle pas du
contenu mais il ya beaucoup de choses
très inquiétante dans ce que le
gouvernement envisage de faire on va
rien offrir effectivement au fil des
jours
on va découvrir au mois d'août au roi
parce que le gouvernement va recevoir
des syndicats sans vraiment leur donner
la vérité des prix jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juillet pendant ce temps là nous
on sera obligé de voter la loi
d'habilitation des ordonnances et ils
vont publier le texte au mois d'août
parce que c'est quand même vers ça qu'on
se dirige alors juste bonjour la
transparence démocratique voilà
troisième partie la dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant on va
changer de sujet avec mickaël zeze de
public sénat qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
on sort michael bonsoir michel pour sa
part laurent bonsoir vous parlez de du
terrorisme après l'action qui a eu lieu
hier sur les champs elysées tentative
d'attentât introduire l'état d'urgence
dans le droit commun c'est ce qui a
demandé
c'est ce que souhaite le ministre de
l'intérieur
quel est votre avis sur la question est
ce vous allez dans le sens du ministre
l'intérieur
non nous n'allons pas de sens et ça
n'est pas un débat nouveau nous savons
que la menace est réelle sérieuse et on
le voit malheureusement en france et
dans d'autres pays
dans d'autres pays dans le monde donc
mais estimons pas cette menace nous
avons un débat sur la manière de la
combattre il ya un discours assez
contradictoires du gouvernement puisque
d'un côté il dit on va sortir de l'état
d'urgence
ça fait déjà trois fois qu'on nous le
promet mais en vérité on va pas vraiment
sortir puis qu'on va faire rentrer dans
le droit commun toutes les dispositions
qu'il ya dedans or ce qui pose problème
c'est qu'il ya des dispositions qui
sinon qu'ils sont plus efficaces qui
peuvent être efficaces dans l'urgence
mais qui ne sont pas forcément dans la
durée de restriction du pouvoir
judiciaire des libertés publiques et
celle là on va les faire entrer dans le
droit commun ne seront plus
exceptionnels comme c'est le cas dans la
droite dans l'état d'urgence et ses
restrictions peuvent être utilisés pour
des choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec ça
le rapport d'amnesty international a
clairement montré il ya quelques
semaines que les dispositions de l'état
d'urgence avait été utilisée pour
réprimer les mains pour interdire ou
réprimer les manifestations à toi un
tout autre objet que celui de la lutte
donc un gérard l'audi r sur place sur
les chapeaux champs elysées qu'il est
nécessaire c'est une nécessité
aujourd'hui de l'introduire dans le
droit commun ils se trompent mais
qu'elle violait quel est le rapport
entre les dispositions lui en voir deux
de retrait du pouvoir judiciaire dans
certains bassins est et ce qui s'est
passé hier
parce que j'ai effectivement entendu
comme vous gérard collomb qui utilisent
cette cet événement pour dire ah ça
justifie bien mais quel est le rapport
entre les deux c'est justement ce qui
est débattu depuis un moment et ce qui
est mis en cause par toute une partie
des professions judiciaires
hier qu'ils disent mais n'ont pour
l'heure n'ont par contre si on veut
ouvrir le débat sur la manière dont on
continue de lutter contre les phénomènes
de radicalisation d'un certain nombre de
deux jeunes français et tout un tas
d'autres dispositions y compris
internationale de lutte contre le
terrorisme etc
oui les fichiers naissent vous en faites
quoi par exemple ça fait des mois
peut-être pouvoir une ou deux années
qu'on ne cesse d'en parler depuis les
attentats de bekasi manque justement sur
ça y est c'est étonnant mais ce qui
manque c'est que justement ces
renseignements doivent pouvoir être
exploitées sur le terrain il faut des
moyens sur le terrain il faut le
renseignement une chose est de
l'accumuler et encore il faut vérifier
qu'on est les dispositions les
dispositifs pour le faire mais ensuite
comment l'exploiter quand on a pas sur
le terrain notamment dans la dendre dans
les dents dans les communes où vivent
des d'aider des jeunes qui sont fichés s
comment est-ce qu'on travaille pour
prévenir ça fait ses salariés de
renseignements michel on en a parlé tout
à l'heure la task force qui a été créé à
l'elysée auprès d' emmanuel macron ne
sera plus chargé d'une simple mission de
coordination mais pourrait
éventuellement avoir un pouvoir de
décision ça veut dire que le pouvoir
appartient dray oui mais au jarret là je
pense qu'on est on est justement dans à
nouveau avec cette mesure dans une
dérive plus globale c'est une dérive de
concentration extrême des pouvoirs c'est
joli mais autour autour du président de
la résidence
ça n'est pas seulement emmanuel macron
c'est une dérive qui ne cesse de
s'amplifier et qui a été beaucoup
amplifié du temps que la sarkozie du
temps de françois hollande et qui va
malheureusement visiblement continuer
avec emmanuel macron ça pose des
problèmes démocratiques ça pose des
problèmes d'efficacité de l'action
gouvernementale
ça pose des problèmes parce que tout ça
conduit à concentrer énormément de gens
ont entendu autour du président de
l'areq mais c'est un problème et
certains bien sûr pouvoir
les mêmes nous disent il faut un travail
d'équipé il faut que le gouvernement
soit soudées etc
et puis au lieu de donner les moyens à
ce gouvernement pouvoirs de bien
travailler et aux administrations de le
faire au service public de le faire au
parlement de contrôler tout cela est
bien on continue de concentrer de
combler ses besoins du présent un risque
c'est un gage d'efficacité quels risques
le gage d'efficacité ni trop mais qu'on
nous promet il faut nous le démontre et
là encore mais il ya un riverain
ben oui je pense qu'à concentrer trop de
pouvoir être trop de décisions
importantes dans les mains d'un seul
homme est en vérité elles ne sont pas
dans les mains d'un seul homme elles
sont dans les mains aussi à côté de cet
homme d'une armée de conseillers de l'ex
dr mary ii alors voilà donc à une il ya
une hypertrophie près de là tout de tout
l'appareil d'état présidentielle au
détriment des des autres institutions du
pays donc c'est une évolution du régime
qui devient au tout point extrêmement
problématique alors à propos de l'état
d'urgence inscrit dans la loi ordinaire
n'est pas laisser tout al'air michael
finir sa phrase il voulais vous dire que
le premier ministre affi a précisé ce
matin que le juge judiciaire aurait son
mot à dire avant toute mesure
administrative donc 7° dénaturer ou et
rassure écoutez compte comme on va avoir
la discussion sur le pen sur
parlementaire on va vérifier cette chose
là une valeur de retour dans le point 2
2 il me reste peu de temps pour vous
parler du sénat et de l'avenir du sénat
et de votre groupe vous avez à peu près
18 sénateurs qui vont être qu'ils vont
remettre en jeu pas à peu près
exactement 18 leur poste est ce que vous
espérez ce que vous êtes sûr et certain
de pouvoir avoir le même nombre en
septembre prochain
non nous ne sommes pas sûr et certain
d'avoir le nomme il ya deux de nos
sénateurs qui ne sont pas renouvelables
dont qui seront qui seront
toujours la d18 sont renouvelables il ya
une série de ces sénateurs qui sont
menacés parce que les la vague
d'élections intermédiaires à changer la
composition du corps électoral
je pense que en tout cas nous
travaillons à cela que nous pouvons
conserver un groupe est censé pouvoir
conserver un groupe
oui nous pensons pouvoir concernés vont
travailler on installe pouvoir regarder
votre fauteuil père laurent que vous
avez regardé les jeux wii
normalement je serai élu sénateur de
paris mais vous savez que les avant de
répondre avec certitude à ça il faut
déjà tant le 30 juin puisque c'est la
date à laquelle les conseils municipaux
se réunissent dans tous les départements
concernés pour désigner les grands les
grands électeurs et donc c'est après la
désignation de ces grands électeurs par
les conseils municipaux que va démarrer
appelons à plein régime
il pourrait y avoir un groupe en marche
au sénat ils vous ont contacté ou non je
pense qu'ils connaissent la statue
visées de vous écouter depuis quarante
cinq minutes
non non ils n'ont rien à attendre n'ont
rien à attendre de nous mais par contre
nous serons des opposants farouches que
nous savons faire
mais toujours mais toujours constructif
et notre groupe continuera à faire
beaucoup de propositions
si le gouvernement dit qu'il peut y
avoir des bonnes idées partout faut
qu'ils nous écoutent d'avant constructif
comme un merci beaucoup merci michael
merci puis à leur merci à vous a tous à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]